That wouldn't bother with all the
football as
well.
I bumped in and it's got to be there
sort of head,
shoulders above anyone else,
terms of the way that hearing him as
influenced by.
And then there's a whole battalion of
people,
everyone from Nina Simone's talk to Van
Morrison know,
uh,
Nick Drake is a Koan,
you know,
a Joni Mitchell.
It's just a,
as a whole sway that people like the
specials and the Qr code.
I was obsessed with the Kule for ages.
I love the smell of them live a couple
of times in the midnight sees that would
great.
Yeah,
it was a couple.
Actually.
A Walden was the water boys.
This is the sea at Cardiff University.
Nineteen 85.
Uh,
they just went straight through the
curfew and played for like three hours,
but that was such a brilliant record and
he was at the peak of his powers.
Mike Scott at that point,
he'd already written songs like
fisherman's blues and things that
appeared later and he played them at the
show and I remember instantly liking
that.
I've never heard it before.
And he played a couple of things.
He played a couple of covers and he just
went on and on and on,
but the way they will change the
instruments that,
uh,
I,
I love that show.
And then the same year I went to
Glastonbury for the first time and the
cure headlined Saturday night,
uh,
that was the head of the door album,
which was a brilliant record,
but they just did a brilliant set and it
was,
and as it used to be,
not quite as clean and neat and tidy as
it is now,
but the pyramid stage,
they had a laser,
they used to be a laser,
the laser,
only the headline,
I could use it.
So the cure got to use the laser and I
was there a bit out of my brains with my
little friend from school.
Um,
unless thunderstorm came into the moon
was going down and like the sun was of
other movements coming up.
The Sun was going down and then there's
just this huge storm came in and there
was thunder and lightning and all the
dry ice was being dragged across the
stage.
It just looked fantastic and they just
played through all the stuff.
Yeah,
that was.
That was amazing.
I was blown away by Glastonbury.
The whole thing of it.
I'm so obsessed by music.
I must have seen about 40 bands like the
cure was.
That was the.